Well, we talked about, a little bit about,
so there's arguments
saying that some people actually employ
violence as means
to draw attention to draw international pressure
to help solve the issue,
so the argument goes
the IRA
not employing violence in Ireland.
We actually, well,
maybe in the UK people will petition to act but in United States or other parts of the world
nobody will care,
and their grievance will never be heard,
and the problem will never be solved.
So how would you respond to that argument?
I think it's a really good question, and it's
a very, very hard one
to answer honestly.
Because this is one of the most, this is a very
dangerous
answer if you answer yes.
I think,
I think however they're,
well I'll make two points. I think first of all
there are ways actually,
and the civil rights movement here
in a way was an example, well okay
there were elements of violence
surrounding it, but it was basically
a peaceful movement.
Ghandi: a peaceful movement.
You don't need to be violent,
but you do need to draw attention.
But violence is only way of drawing attention.
I think secondly, this is the debate I really
had with the IRA,
and shouldn't feign in the last two years before I
left office
my argument to them was,
and this is again the importance of the dialogue
we had, it's worth saying this.
When I first met
Gerry Adams and Martin McGuinness,
and it was obviously
a huge thing
for me to
meet them and so on, and I remember there was a major
questions as to whether I
would shake hands with them or not.
And I met them and I did shake hands with them.
And later that day I went to visit a unionist area,
and
the whole of what looks very respectable kind of grannies
sort of hanging around doing shopping and everything, and I went to this shopping percent, and they suddenly
morphed into these screaming, shouting, bullying
grannies,
waving rubber gloves at me, and I'm sorry,
I got very alarmed. I was so so tired,
I couldn't get the rubber gloves thing at all,
and I thought maybe they'd been doing the washing and just come out
quickly or something and then
someone said no, it was because you were shaking hands with
Gerry Adams. You should have been wearing rubber gloves
because he's such an evil person you oughtn't be shaking hands
with him.
So anyway, there's this
whole business about meeting them and being able to talk to them
allowed me over time to establish this relationship
where we started to have a real debate,
and I was saying, and I understand why you may think
that you may think that your violence brought
this issue to people's attention,
but believe me we are now at this stage
where your violence is the thing that stops this issue from being resolved.
So it's interesting at both levels. It's difficult to answer your question.
Yes, you have to bring it to people's attention. Maybe
violence isn't the only way you can do it,
but the second thing is
the act of engagement
if it can establish
a relationship
means
that suddenly
the power of persuasion is at least on the table.
And I think in the end what Gerry Adams and Martin McGuinness needed
due to huge convincing by me,
I think they were
coming to their own conclusion.
Finally what clinched the Northern Ireland deal
was the IRA just saying
okay we're
we're going away.
You know, we're not surrendering,
we're just disappearing.
And actually that was
then the moment when unionism was faced
with its moment of truth
because then the entire justification for
the refusal
was then moved, and that was the moment of
which
Ian Paisley had to decide and be very decided the right way whether
really the problem was violence or
really the problem was
they weren't of the same tribe.